the brutal star series Spartacus was
known for its highly stylized Gore and
its many Liberties taken with historical
fact lasting Four Seasons it covers one
of the greatest Rebel leaders in history
his allies and his many many foes here's
what the cast of the popular show is up
to now expectations were high for Liam
McIntyre when he stepped in to replace
Andy Whitfield as the main character of
Spartacus but he arguably did quite well
in the titular role while certainly
different from Whitfield McIntyre's turn
to Spartacus took the character from a
gladiator slave to a freedom fighter
Commander remaining one of his most
famous roles to this day
spread word to every slave yet beneath
you that even the mighty Republic please
when struck
in the years since McIntyre has been
quite busy both in his career and family
life from appearing in major TV shows
like the flash to providing the voice of
JD Phoenix in the Gears of War video
game series in June of 2022 he and his
wife Aaron announced on social media
that they're expecting their second
child
Lucy lawless's Lucretia is one of the
early villains of Spartacus and the
prequel season gods of the Arena her
unexpected return in season 2 was a
welcome surprise for many fans both of
Lawless as an actress and of her
ruthless Roman Aristocrat since her days
is the titular heroine in Xena Warrior
Princess Lawless has been a major player
in both TV and film since Spartacus
she's been a cast member in series such
as Salem and Ash vs Evil Dead currently
Lawless stars in my life is murder as
the private investigator Alexa Crow and
provided the voice of nunchuck in the
2022 animated film minions the rise of
Gru even though John Hannah's cruelly
ambitious body artist didn't last long
on Spartacus he is considered a superb
early antagonist while viewers can often
feel Sympathy for the character's plates
those sentiments are repeatedly dashed
upon seeing how manipulative and cunning
body it is
was taken years and the price of blood
but At Last I See For What You Are
a man who holds no one in a steam Beyond
himself
Hannah has appeared in television and
movies since the early 1990s with his
most memorable role being Jonathan
Carnahan the comic relief in the mummy
franchise Hannah remains incredibly
active on screen starring as Dr jet
Bishop in the ongoing series transplant
and appearing in shows like Dirk
gently's holistic detective agency and
the victim
in a show littered with tragic endings
for most of the central characters
crixus the Dependable rival turned Ally
of Spartacus portrayed by Manu Bennett
also meets a grim fate but Bennett had a
fantastic run with the character up
until that point Bennett has had many
major credits in the years since
Spartacus perhaps best known for playing
Deathstroke in the CW Series arrow and a
Zog in Peter Jackson's The Hobbit
trilogy recently Bennett posted on
Instagram that he considers one of the
most important roles of his career being
in the 2022 film muru which spotlighted
the controversial Terror raids carried
out in 2007 by New Zealand Police the
actor admitted that he was initially
hesitant to take on the role of the
oppressor but after a heart-to-heart
with the lead star Cliff Curtis he was
convinced to take the part Bennett told
the otago Daily Times They say a hero is
only as strong as their villain or
protagonist is only as strong as the
antagonist you have to bring that energy
out and that's my job as an actor many
fans consider Peta mensa's turn as the
stern and stoic on Emmaus a formidable
presence in Spartacus animes is critical
not only for training Spartacus and the
other gladiators but for also becoming a
key part of the revolt against the
Romans is this not enough
how many more must die I'll see which
one
Mensa has often featured in shows and
movies with high levels of tension and
action and that Trend continues to this
day the actor is set to Star as Governor
Gatto in Rise a thriller centered on a
Nigerian princess's desperate mission to
save her sister from the clutches of
Boko Haram Mensa has also delivered
heart-pounding performances in the 2022
horror films hypochondriac and the devil
conspiracy and played the blind master
in the 2021 movie Snake Eyes the latest
installment of the GI Joe film franchise
Mensa has also continued working for the
small screens in Spartacus with his
credits including series like Sleepy
Hollow as well as playing the villainous
kovas in Marvel's Agents of Shield
Daniel fiorical's Agron is one of
spartacus's most trusted lieutenants
even though he's surrounded by doomed
characters and even Witnesses the
heartbreaking murder of his brother Duro
at the hands of a Roman guard Agron is
one of the few Rebels who survives to
the end of the series in the years since
the end of Spartacus furygol took on the
role of Vijay demura in the popular soap
opera Days of Our Lives and appeared in
films like Pacific Rim Uprising and the
upcoming Heidi Queen of the mountain
outside of films and TV furgal has also
been busy publishing his own graphic
novel fractured shards telling TV
Insider it's been an absolute blast it's
been phenomenal you pitched the story
you write it and then you see the artist
and colorists do their things it's such
a fun collaborative effort to say that
Nick e tarabay's character Asher is
sneaky would certainly be an
understatement first as a slave and then
as a willing servant to the Romans Asher
does whatever it takes to survive which
includes stabbing anyone who gets in his
way in the back yet in the end the
traitor reaps what he sows and is slain
by the former slave Navia for his
horrible crimes against her
[Music]
following the end of the Stars series
tarabay had a prominent role as cautier
in the Sci-Fi series The expanse as well
as smaller roles in series like arrow
and motherland Fort Salem more recently
the actor has appeared in the cleaning
lady in 2022 as well as taking on the
recurring part of eclipso in the DC
series Star Girl tarabay's voice can
also be heard in video games like
bioware's Anthem and the dark pictures
House Of Ashes the whole Spartacus Saga
began when articular hero was forcefully
separated from his lover Surah this
tragic romance made it difficult for
actress Katrina law to enter the series
as the new woman in spartacus's life the
slave turned Warrior Mira however
throughout the series Miriam becomes
much more than just the protagonist's
lover playing a pivotal role supporting
the Revolt leader in their Fight For
Freedom following her work on the star's
action drama law has continued a
prolific career in film and television
her most recognizable role in recent
years is arguably that of Special Agent
Jessica Knight in NCIS and NCIS Hawaii
but she's also had other major parts
like Karen beach in the Thriller series
the oath and the formidable Nisa Al
ghoul in DC's Arrow while Ian McIntyre
replacing Andy Whitfield wasn't the only
actor swap to take the place on
Spartacus Cynthia dye Robinson stepping
in for Leslie Ann bran to play Navia for
the 2012 Vengeance season was for
altogether different reasons with Brent
choosing to leave due to scheduling
conflicts and production delays the
character Avia had endured horrific
treatment as a slave in the Roman mines
and her transformation into a Fearless
Warrior is fiercely performed by a die
Robinson
his but single reason crushes spread my
life
to Tom Spartacus with vision of his end
and die Robinson's other prominent roles
since include Nadine Memphis and the TV
adaptation of shooter Ramona Garrity in
the acclaimed crime Saga power and
Suicide Squad Mastermind Amanda Waller
in the arrowverse though a Dye
Robinson's biggest recent role is
probably that of queen regent Muriel in
Amazon's the Lord of the Rings the rings
of power when describing the part to
Men's Journal she said it's complicated
a regent Queen is not fully in power yet
essentially I'm trying to lead my people
and decide which direction the society
is going to take it's a fork in the road
moment
as alethia Viva Bianca had a fascinating
role in Spartacus not just as the wife
of the hero's arch nemesis Glover but
also as the possible mother of
spartacus's child whether that last bit
is truth or trickery the controversial
infant eventually leads to the Roman
Noble woman's downfall Bianca has
appeared in several Productions after
Spartacus including the popular 2015
holiday film a prince for Christmas but
she skilled back her on-screen acting in
more recent years instead focusing on
producing and directing the climate
crisis documentary generation gnd in
September of 2022 she posted on
Instagram that she and her family
finally settled in a new home after
spending a good amount of time moving
around she said in the last two and a
half years we moved six times across
oceans and state lines that's a lot for
anyone but especially a lot if you have
little people in tow Craig Parker's
Roman Commander Gaius Claudius bobber
quickly becomes the despised Nemesis of
Spartacus at the beginning of his
turbulent Saga whereas Spartacus as
other early enemy body it just pretends
to be on the titular character side
globber acts with open arrogance and
contempt towards the thrition even when
reaching out to fight alongside him as a
military ally I shall take my leave when
Spartacus full a task long overdue in
its completion yeah now within grasp
after globber causes Spartacus to lose
everything including his freedom and his
wife Surah the rebel leader scores a
major victory in his war against the
Romans when he finally gets revenge in
the aptly titled Vengeance season
following Spartacus Parker has appeared
in minor roles in many different TV
series including Yuri in the Romantic
dramedy good trouble and in the 2018
Revival of Charmed but his biggest roles
since Spartacus are arguably as Stefan
narcissus in the historical drama Reign
and Guy Warner in the New Zealand soap
opera shortland Street the actors also
cast in the upcoming Thriller a social
contract alongside Lord of the Rings
alumni Sean Aston when the status of
Spartacus was uncertain due to the
health concerns of lead star Andy
Whitfield Dustin Claire stepped in to
become the main character gonicus and
the prequel season gods of the Arena
gonicus was popular enough to return in
later seasons and join the slave revolt
against the Romans using his legendary
fighting skills as a gladiator to
devastating effect Claire has been a TV
star for some time and continues to
feature in many different Productions to
this day most recently the actor played
a major part in the series surviving
summer as Tomo Gibson and the character
George Michael in the 2022 drama film
seriously read beginning in Spartacus
vengeance actress Alan Hallman plays the
formidable Germanic Warrior saxa who
joins the slave revolt after being freed
by Spartacus and Agron as part of the
Rebel forces saksa fights valiantly and
eventually forms a complicated yet
strong bond with ganicus making it all
the more painful for the ex-gladiator
when she tragically dies in his arms
during a battle with the Romans the
character may have met a tragic end on
Spartacus but the part LED home into a
substantial career in both TV and film
she's earned credits on major shows
including Lethal Weapon into the
Badlands NCIS and NCIS New Orleans in
film Hallman recently appeared in The
Matrix resurrections as the character
Echo this year played by panahima Taylor
is a later addition to the rebel cause
joining the cast in Spartacus vengeance
he quickly becomes one of the
rebellion's most Ardent supporters
though he initially has no idea how to
fight and even opposes Spartacus however
articular hero chooses to train him and
from then on Nasir is extremely devoted
to the war effort he's seemingly
rewarded by the gods for that devotion
getting to live his remaining days with
his lover Agra Taylor has mostly worked
on projects in his native New Zealand
since the end of Spartacus including
major roles in dirty laundry and the
broken one Mysteries his most notable
role since this year may be that of Bert
Thompson in West Side appearing in 49
episodes of the series since 2015.
foreign